hi Scott you got it do it so I know
that's degrading then the other voice my
head goes yes that's why it's so hot
well no this is not happening I'm your
host raw wood jr. now tonight's episode
it's not for the faint of heart in fact
you might even want to cover your ears
because tonight
[Music]
it
something y'all might know this
gentleman from his works on the NBC
series Hannibal but the real fans known
from kids in the hall Scott Thompson
everybody people are different aren't
they cuz for me I see this and I want to
smell it
[Laughter]
that's right and I'm gay I mean I mean
that's how much of a perv I am like
out even care of his lady parts we
learned her I just like the good stuff
God smell anyway maybe I'm a little bi
funk is funk right people is funk so I
just get a little bit on me for later
yeah a little bit of a doggy bag
[Applause]
right what kind of a job would I be if I
didn't lead a little bit of my sente but
a mark the stage anyways thanks Tori I
want to talk about a time in my life
when I was pretty down pretty depressed
anybody out there ever been depressed
imagine asking that question in his
strip club anybody ever been down
everybody just gone out and saw naked
women you don't know to make you feel
like life isn't horrible never happened
to anyone out there but it was really
bad like it was a really bad time my
life I was really down this that kind of
depression where when the light bulb
burns out you don't change it you just
abandoned the room
so and you know when everybody has
different ways of coping you know with
depression you know they've got that you
know got the the best ones the standard
ones drugs and alcohol that's not my
thing I can still do them and I
certainly use it to help but my thing is
sex
I'm a horndog I am I'm a middle-aged man
whore and I used sex I'm not proud of it
but I know if I was straight I would
definitely have a hooker habit I know
definitely a stripper habit and so uh
what I did what I did was was uh I was
feeling bad about myself I want to feel
good and you know I know you're CEO but
you're a gay man gay men aren't doing
that anymore
you're all getting married you're all
big I can't even say it we're not let's
do a can get it open Aramis
seems like a foreign word but I can say
it we not all of us you know are out
there getting married and adopting
special-needs children right some of us
just aren't made for office work you
know I mean you got to have some agents
out there in the field bring it back to
hard data for the scientists so is what
afternoon yes it gets worth was an
afternoon
I'm an actor I've got afternoons off and
well that wasn't the real reason I this
bathhouse yes it was a bathhouse people
I know I was a bit of a bathhouse Betty
that's what they called me it was an
afternoon and two-for-one the blockers
two-for-one it's called an early bird
special and so I went out there because
there's a thing about sex and me I mean
I grew up as a little you know a little
nerdy did not good at any sport I
can say nerd you're lots a nerd really
good at any sports but then when I
discovered I discovered I was
really good at it so I find you to work
out so I went down to my favorite spot
and what I like about bath houses for so
many things I liked about them from the
lack of a digital trail which is lovely
to the fact that the back houses have
the kinds of men that I like the bath
houses have become sort of a put a
closet for the third world sort of a
Muslim closet sort of I do a lot of
outreach to the Muslim community
I mean they should be paying me to help
those men adapt but this bath house all
had all my favorite kinds of guys
balding brown men with accents and
flip-flops hey I've seen more Indian men
explode than a pakistani peacekeeper in
kashmir yourself so i went out for a
little bit about reach to the muslim
community and so i go to go to my
favorite bathhouse and it's a strange
subculture the bathhouse subculture i
call it a subculture so it doesn't seem
as perverted and low but yeah there's
two kinds of men at a bathhouse
there's the wolves who prowl I'm a wolf
proud the other kind are the trapdoor
spiders they lay and wait in their lairs
watching with their compound eyes and
when a wolf falls into their lair they
jump on his dick and they ride him till
they've got his life fluid that's how it
works
so anyways I'm there it's like the
afternoon I'm wandering around like a
wolf howling occasionally at the moon
and I look in this layer and I see the
oddest trapdoor spider all I can see are
his eyes he's on his hands and his knees
he stressed completely in black rubber
all I can see are his eyes pretty pretty
eyes
pretty dead eyes and he has a hose
coming out of his mouth that's attached
to a funnel and it's all duct-taped to
his head and then he has a sign around
his neck that says the human urinal I
know I know I know what you're thinking
you admire him for going for what he
wants but you question his fashion sense
right that's why you went like this and
I totally agree I think she should have
taken a page from coco chanel Coco
Chanel said before you leave the house
always remove one article of clothing
right whether it be a bracelet a scarf
an IV bag
I myself would have removed a sign I
would have let the funnel speak for
itself
[Applause]
you're a perv
does it mean you can't be subtle so
anyways I'm wandering around and I keep
looking into this lair and he's still
there hopeful on his hands and knees
waiting for a wolf for the full-bladder
to drop in and I keep looking at him
when I'm not having a great day you know
I've been wandering around I'm there for
hours hours and I keep looking at I mean
going des that's intriguing I'm gonna
caveman right when you're bored gay you
have a head start you know I mean I've
got everything that two to eleven men
can do to one another and much of it on
skates that's where I am so I don't
judge
like I don't judge people by their sex
life my god
when I was a kid just being a could
land you in jail no I don't care what
weirdness people are into but I keep
looking at him and going cos Scott you
gotta do it God I mean your friends will
never forgive you if you don't so I
think no that's degrading then the other
voice my head goes yes that's why it's
so hard
so eventually I look in and and then
I've been as I said for hours so I mean
people eventually I have to go right and
when you're a man my age and you have a
chance to pee you take it you take god
I'm thinking of bringing the human
urinal on a long car ride I tell you you
definitely sell them it's Shark Tank
[Applause]
so I'm actually I go just go for it so I
leap into his lair and I lo pover
howling occasionally and then I pull my
unit out and I lay it on the lip of his
fascinator and then he waves me away
grandly like Maggie Smith in Downton
Abbey with these words sorry Scott not a
fan you think you've hit rock bottom
no you haven't hit rock bottom until
your pee isn't good enough for the human
urinal thank you very much